hey guys it's max for max tech in this
video I'll be sharing my experience
moving from the latest spec down MacBook
Pro to an old MacBook Air and seeing if
it's usable in 2019 I'll share some
surprising finds some big downsides and
some tips to improve performance if you
have an old Mac now this experience
started when I was at a Best Buy and saw
a salesperson suggesting someone the
base MacBook Air from 2017 which they
are still selling for $1000 meaning that
people are still buying them I would
never suggest a new one for that price
but I know that there's people out there
looking for use max at around 4 to maybe
$500 so I decided to take a look and see
if it's worth it let's jump right in and
start my first experience was just
plugging in the Mac to charge up the
dead battery I was never as huge of a
fan of Mac safe like some other
reviewers but there definitely is a
satisfying click when the two magnets
snap together that you cannot replicate
with USB type-c the other handy feature
is the LED light lets you know when
you're charging I love the look of the
new MacBooks but ding this thing it
really brings you back there's just
something special about the glowing
Apple logo that elevates the Mac
experience at least if you're an Apple
fan that is opening up the Mac you can't
help but notice that huge silver bezel
that jumps right out it is massive but
for some reason the aluminum helps make
it less annoying looking compared to
Windows laptops with huge black plastic
vessels one thing that surprised me was
the size now it's not large or thick or
heavy but it is noticeably larger
compared to the new 13-inch MacBook Air
or pro with that set if you're buying a
used one you'll be very happy with a
thin and light design now on to the
biggest disappointment that I was
expecting and also kind of dreading
ahead of time the display pressing down
the power button to resurrect this Mac
resulted in a soft image with colors
that looked a bit off compared to the
same image on my new Mac of course touch
ID isn't available so I logged in the
old fashioned way and was greeted with
the high sierra desktop to be honest the
wallpaper looked terrible and watching
our own youtube videos look worse than
I've ever seen them before
and reading text on websites was painful
with that said if you haven't owned a
high-res display before you likely won't
notice as huge of
as I did but the 1400 by 900 screen will
definitely look worse than your phone
the biggest problem which is probably
worse than sharpness is color accuracy I
immediately noticed that photos and
videos just didn't look quite right and
that's because compared to the new DCI
p3 displays in most ipads iphones and
macs this display can't even show 60% of
srgb meaning you're missing from between
40 to 70% of actual realistic real-world
colors because of this even though I
will be talking about photo and video
editing in just a bit if you do any kind
of color editing that is important I
would look elsewhere my MacBook Air only
comes with a 1.6 gigahertz dual core i5
processor and 4 gigabytes of RAM but
thankfully Apple still offers Mac OS
updates all the way back to 2012 Macs
and Apple's newer operating systems have
improved performance and efficiency so
the first thing I did was upgrade to the
just release Mac OS Catalina to get the
best performance out of this old MacBook
Air I would highly recommend updating
but before you do you need to make sure
that you have enough space and that
you're not relying on 32-bit versions of
apps that are no longer supported to
maximize efficiency thankfully our
sponsor for this video CleanMyMac X will
help you do just that in a lot more
CleanMyMac X will search and delete
those unsupported 32-bit apps the right
way with no leftover files and the
updater feature will make sure you get
the replacements when they're available
if your current Mac is feeling a bit
sluggish CleanMyMac X's dozen of cleanup
and tune-up tools will help you speed up
your Mac remove malware and adware clean
your system junk files in a hidden
clutter and build an interactive map of
your Mac storage CleanMyMac X is super
easy to use and removes over 30 gigs of
junk from the average users Mac while
speeding it up so why not give it a try
by clicking the link down in the video
description now with the MacBook Air and
tip-top shape software wise it was time
to put it to the test and see how it
handles my normal workload loading up
webpages was noticeably slower than my
new Mac but definitely usable if you
only have 4 gigs of sister RAM and maybe
even if you have 8 and you also need to
have a bunch of tabs open like I do I
would suggest looking at Safari instead
of Chrome because it runs smoother and
uses less memory
run faster when having a typical
workload of about 10 tabs Catalina was
doing a great job of making everything
work it wrote about 1.8 gigs of files to
the fairly fast SSD and was using about
3.3 gigabytes of RAM with a lot of it
being compressed with about 10 tabs open
I did notice some extra lag when
scrolling that wasn't there if I had six
to seven tabs open and this is without
any other major apps running so if
you're a top junkie you'll need at least
eight gigs of RAM or some major patience
navigating around was surprisingly good
even though this old trackpad isn't the
super cool adjustable force touch design
it's large smooth and responsive so most
people will be very happy with it now
the keyboard was a different experience
I spend a lot of my day typing so I
thought I might actually love the old
chiclet design which has about three
times the key travel but to be honest I
didn't yes the key travel does feel
better but because the keys themselves
are smaller with bigger spacing between
the keys my typing accuracy went down
reliability isn't a problem with these
old keyboards which is an OPS ID but I
prefer to type on the latest version of
the butterfly keyboard backlighting was
also distracting at night with lights
built all around the keys but if you're
coming from a different laptop you'll
likely have the same kind or maybe no
backlighting at all
behind these keys we have hidden
speakers and the volume surprised me
we've been testing different Windows
laptops lately like the 2019 XPS
two-in-one and even though that is over
two thousand dollars once backed out the
speakers are a fair bit quieter than
this old MacBooks
the sound quality was noticeably worse
than a new MacBooks but for usability
when listening to music podcasts or
watching videos the loudspeakers are
surprisingly capable another
surprisingly usable part of the system
is the i/o which actually I guess isn't
too surprising all of the new Macs use
only USB type-c which works fine for me
most of the time and I'd have to use
dongles too often but for somebody that
edits photos and videos all the time
having that SD card slot is just so nice
we also have two USB type 8 ports and a
single Thunderbolt 2 port which is
enough for most people now if you don't
need that SD card slot it can be easily
used to cheaply expand the internal SSD
with these flush-mount SD cards these
aren't super fast but they'll do a good
job for photos videos and other files if
you're like me and have a MacBook Air
that has 128 gigs of SSD space this is
something that you can't really pull off
well with the new MacBook and another
thing a new MacBook can't do is to be
able to swap out the SSD after you buy
it since everything is soldered in the
stock 128 gigabyte SSD is surprisingly
fast but if you really want to get
serious with your storage you can
actually upgrade to a larger and faster
nvme SSD drive to speed things up not
many people know that up from 2015 which
is my model and on they actually had a
4x m2 slot you just need a little cheap
adapter to be able to use ultra fast and
affordable SSDs I'll go ahead and leave
a link to one down in the video
description now my battery life was
surprisingly good with about seven hours
of average use because this battery is
in pretty good condition but if your
MacBook is dying fast you can actually
swap out the battery in a matter of
minutes with around a forty to fifty
dollar and third-party battery pack now
the last thing we need to take a deeper
dive on is the performance looking at
raw power and Geekbench 4 we have a
multi-core score of 5800 which is
actually slower than an iPhone 7 or the
base model $329 iPad this fairly low
performance is mainly because the
dual-core CPU is a fifth generation and
that's even for the 2017 model as well
whereas new Windows laptops are shipping
with 10th gen Intel CPUs for normal use
like email web browsing and watching
videos the performance is good enough
and optimized Apple apps work decently
well as I mentioned previously the
display isn't up to par for color
critical work but if you're interested
in some simple photo editing I would
highly recommend the new optimized and
updated Photos app I edited a variety of
raw and JPEG images and while at times
there was some delay when using sliders
and swapping photos the experience was
definitely usable based on what I saw
there though I would highly avoid using
Lightroom and other heavier apps the
main slowdown was likely because of the
four gigs of RAM so I would suggest
closing everything in the background
when editing photos or videos this is
something that cleaned my Mac
Exce can help you do really easily so
make sure to check out the link below to
speed up your Mac now on to video
editing the latest version of Final Cut
has some optimizations but even still 4k
video editing is really slow and choppy
and if you want to edit H EVC files from
your iphone or gopro they literally will
not play because the old processor can't
handle them it literally just kind of
pauses and doesn't play 1080p and 720p
video is definitely possible so if you
want to cut together some simple videos
Final Cut where iMovie will do just fine
so what did I learn overall from this
experience and what I suggest buying
something else instead
well first off do not let yourself or
anybody else for that matter
buy one of these for $1000 at Best Buy
but if you're thinking about spending
somewhere around $400 on Craigslist
this laptop could do a better job I have
regular tasks than I expected make sure
to have the latest software and use
optimized apps like Safari and it'll do
a surprisingly good job for these basic
things and for an Internet machine which
will offer you long lasting battery life
decent speakers and a good keyboard and
trackpad the other thing I learned is
that modern heavier apps and tasks
really push this machine to its limits
and beyond at this point so if you want
to edit photos or videos on a laptop
you'll want to step up to a 2018 air or
maybe a 2017 based MacBook Pro which
will cost not that much more money
especially if you're looking at new
deals and then those have sales on them
and that will run a lot faster but
you'll also have a much better
experience with a nice display that can
actually show you all of the colors let
me know what your experience is like if
you're using an old Mac and if you check
out clean my Mac X by using a link down
below let me know how much it helped to
clean up your system and speed it up as
well click above to subscribe and down
below to enable notifications and if you
want to see another video we have a
couple of great ones right over there
listen max max tech and I will see you
in the next one
[Music]